Në përmjët objekteve arkeologike të ekspuzuarëa, vërtetot se truali unë ka qeni banuar nga iliret dhe shqiptare të në vaʃdimsi qe prej 4.000 vitës.
Objekte të arkeologike të ekspuzuarëa në muze, armës bukurime ceramike, bronzijeti, janë originale.
Qe prej lash sis, truali unë është bër objekti puštimëve të huoja dukenisur nga shekuli i tred parahereson,
kur vendi usulmuan nga Romakët të cilit të puštuan pas tri luftrave iliro Romakë.
Me gjithatë të, si puštimi Romakë edhe Dundjet Slave, nukë asimiluan populsin vendase.
Ky fenomen dëshmon për një shembul të larthet në kulture të shqiptareve, të cilit në funn të shekuli të dhënbëdhjet arritëm të krijojnë shtetine par të arbrejtë.
Në salen e lash sis jan të ekspuzuarëa.
Objekte të kultures i lire para qitetare, shekuli i tët dhej në të paraqrishtit.
Objekte të kultures i lire qitetare, shekuli i kater dhej i tred paraqrishtit.
Modelja njes Liburne.
Ceramika i lire, shekuli i dudh dhej i par paraqrishtit.
Qutet i antik i Albanopolit dhe objekte të gjetura në të.
Statuja në artemisit.
Arme i lire.
Piro, teuta.
Luftera dhej liro Romakë, piktur murale.
Objekte të kultures se hershme, shekuli i shtad dhej i tëtë.
Ceramika në Mesjed.
Bronzi në Mesjed.
Emblema e prinsipata sarbrit.
Harta e prinsipata sarbrit.